thank you so much aarthi so we have an
amazing panel lined up for you today
we have actually assembled for experts
in their field representing Python or
and Julia so all that matters in data
science because all that non open source
stuff nobody cares about before we get
started I'd like to very briefly
introduce myself i'm james powell i'll
be your moderator today i have some
questions in reserve to ask these
panelists but the purpose of this of
this panel is for you to ask them
questions so the moment you feel like
there's something that you have a
burning desire to know raise your hand
and we'll run a mic to you and you'll be
able to hear the wisdom of our great
panelists that said I'd like to start
off by giving our panelist an
opportunity to introduce themselves to
tell you a little bit about their
background their experiences in data
science their experience in the open
source community and they can also if
they'd like mention how excited they are
to be here today at my dad New York this
is an amazing event let's give a round
of applause for Leah okay takes the fun
hi I'm Stefan Karpinski one of the
creators of the Julia programming
language which if you're unfamiliar with
it is a relatively new language we
started the project about five years ago
it's been out there in the public for
the last three years it is a high-level
dynamic language that should feel really
really familiar if you're used to
programming in Python or are but it has
performance comparable to c or c++ it
also sort of mary's a lot of the ideas
that have traditionally been in two very
different camps of sort of low-level and
high-level programming languages into
one single language i'm going to talk a
little bit about that am I in my talk it
I think 230 or something I actually used
to work as a data scientist at Etsy did
a lot of machine learning collaborative
filtering sorts of things mostly my
everybody sort of has their their hammer
that they like to look at everything and
see nails with mine tends to be spectral
methods mate linear algebra but yeah I
haven't haven't actually done that much
machine learning hands
myself lately because i'm busy building
tools for other people to do that hi I'm
Jared Lander I think I'm here because
James are trying to get me killed so I
am in an hour fanatic so much to the
extent that you know I actually have an
autographed copy West McKinney's python
book and I have not opened it but you
know language stuff aside i'm actually
not my real thing is a data scientist
that term gets thrown around but I'm
it's not about the language so much
while I enjoy programming an R and I
have fun it's about the statistics
behind it so my specialties are in you
know educating people in using data
science methods or programming methods
it's in developing models to help detect
fraud or subversive players and networks
or identifying outstanding football
players so I believe we're here to talk
about machine learning so I will keep
the our stuff to a minimum hey so I'm
andreas Miller I'm one of the core
developers of cycle my backgrounds in
machine learning and machine learning
researcher and now thanks to NY you can
work on second learn full time so they
support me as a research engineer and so
I see myself pretty much as a tool
builder so I don't do a lot of data
science my day-to-day stuff I mostly
work really on so I could learn so that
other people can do machine learning
easily hey my name is Julia lintern I'm
a date and science instructor at Metis
boot camp we are a 12-week boot camp
that takes students from all different
backgrounds and teaches them data
science and in 12 weeks so we cover
everything you want to know about Python
and machine learning and move on to more
intricate topics such as topic modeling
and sentiment analysis on NLP and all
sorts of things so it's really really
cool experience my background previous
to that was I worked as a quantitative
engineer at JetBlue and believe it or
not they weren't quite ready for data
science so I
I left some so I don't see any questions
from the audience just yet so i'll start
off with my own question panelists what
do you think the most overhyped issue in
machine learning is today and you can
say neural networks if you'd like neural
networks and why I mean if you review
read a hasty trip giannis book 10 years
ago they did not like neural networks
they really they sort of devote just a
few pages to it and shove it all the way
in allison and so they're really popular
back in the 80s and 90s and they got
unpopular another popular again for a
good reason though they have made
enormous advancements in the capability
to process these or new algorithms and
new processing by not new more
processing power that said it's not a
panacea it can't do everything well that
it's awesome it's not it's not that one
hammer that we use for every single they
always say it shouldn't be at least so I
i think the stanford people didn't like
it because they are statisticians so
they care about Ohio statisticians hmm
bio status bio statisticians yeah but so
neural networks are great for prediction
but not great for analyzing your model
and so you can't understand what's
really going on so statisticians don't
like that because they try to make
inferences about process so for
prediction I think it's they're pretty
good and I don't think they're actually
overhyped maybe too much money thrown at
them but they're pretty good working
pretty well and actually there's not
much new algorithm so the things the
great make breakthroughs they use
standard back prop from the 80s and LLC
em which was done by a fighter in the
90s so actually the algorithms are not
really good breakthrough so it's more
like there's enough data now and enough
computation that stuff works okay cool
Jen um yeah I would have to say neural
nets as well I'm coming from my
perspective we want to be able to work
with tools that have a lot of
transparency that we can learn from and
it's all about that iterative process
when you're designing a model and not
being able to see really what the model
is doing as much as is tough so you know
when you're in that exploratory phase
you learned so much from the inner of my
process and not being able to see that
transparency is difficult so I'm going
to say something that I'm a little
tentative about because i'm not entirely
sure whether it's hype or not but I sort
of have these like I'm not not entirely
positive and that is spark and and I I
don't know because people are very
excited about spark they're using it for
machine learning I've also seen some
disturbing things in their in their
source code like you can't have you know
your indices for sparse matrix can't go
above you know 64,000 that seems crazy
like that's but but I don't know so I'm
sort of throwing that out there is like
a for people to like refute or support I
don't know I totally support that so
spark I actually had a talk at PAGASA my
thing telling people not to use spark
for machine learning so spark is great
for like doing the pre-processing of
your data going from like jensen stuff
two floating point numbers but then
afterwards I haven't really seen many
applications that use spark that haven't
couldn't have used like so I could learn
or panas or because like the mushy
detail and what you actually want to do
machine learning is often fairly small
and the algorithm is like if you
distribute to stuff your distributor and
enforce they get so much slower it's
crazy you don't want to do that I have
to say I'm personally really excited
about spark I think that it does have
some capabilities that we can't find
elsewhere for example collaborative
filtering has some really strong
capabilities there and just that it
allows us to circumvent the world of a
dupe makes me really happy
do you agree with andreas about the it
sort of being stronger in the
pre-processing than in the actual
machine learning analysis part I can't
say that I've had enough hands on with
it to see that distinction um but I look
forward to trying yeah I'm sort of with
the pre-processing thing too so once
you've processed your data is usually a
badass eyes you can fit on a large
laptop or a server a single server so
you'll need to go crazy vol all these
distributed algorithms are nice makes
life a little easier but most of the
time you write pre-process it and then
run it on a single machine so we have a
question from our audience hi I just
wanted to ask a question about null
models and the fundamentals of
statistics so a lot of machine learning
goes isn't it is a great extension of
the world of statistics but a lot of the
tutorials a lot of the content out there
doesn't deal with the null the null
hypothesis the null model the idea of
randomness so I was just wondering if
you guys could address the point of the
null either on in terms of education or
in terms of you know like getting people
to think in this way or you know tools
to look at the null model so we know
what we're looking at is actually I
guess you could say statistically
significant the answer is going to
depend on what century I'll give the
answer in so even though I'm trained as
a statistician more than anything else I
hate the holiday of no models and
hypothesis tests and I hate when I see
people learn them in high school in
college they served a purpose a century
ago even 20 years ago 15 years ago maybe
they served a purpose when we couldn't
do things like cross-validation easily
but nowadays even the idea is the
testicle significance a p-value was
arbitrarily chosen by ra fisher 100
years ago where did point oh five point
0 1 point 1 come from he chosen because
he liked them and i even nowadays i
never even looked for p values and i
don't really look for statistical
significance if it makes sense in the
model it makes sense regardless if it's
significant is that point 49 is a point
5 10 point 0 for 9 point 05 1 like what
does
really matter so I'm happy to see people
moving farther and farther away from the
whole null model hypothesis test so what
do you do then if you're trying to
decide whether an effect exists or not
well according to Andy Gelman it always
exists with enough data is never going
to be exactly zero so we should stop
obsessing over is the effect zero and
then just see doesn't improve predictive
performance in the model using
cross-validation so that actually ties
into something I've been thinking about
recently in this area which is sort of
plotting p values versus effect size
like how much how much how much effect
size can you prove as opposed to trying
to boil it down to a single number I
mean it's almost entirely going to be
effect size when it comes to P values I
think it's if as your data approaches
infinity the probability of rejection
approaches one so if you get enough data
you're always going to see something now
the question is how big is that effect
like the effect size it might be near
zero so dozen have any implications in
the real world but if it improves your
model it gives you a better fit sure
I'll add in um I think there's so many
different interesting ways to see the
check the validity of the models so on p
value of course and traditional
statistic um application so is one way
but with amazing tools that we have at
our disposal with Python in etc we can
look at things in terms of which
features are powerful by implementing
them incremental e using on grid search
techniques and just you know example you
know our decision tree will provide us
with so much information on feature
importances and such so we have other
ways of validating and finding you know
which which features are incredibly
powerful other than just the p value so
we have options
so we have a question the audience but
while while we run the Mike out to that
question I'd like to ask one small
follow-up what is the difference between
us statistics data mining and machine
learning you get paid more depending
which one you call yourself so my answer
so usually people ask me this question a
lot and usually my own souris statistic
cares about inference while machine
learning cares about prediction we do we
care of a prediction too so okay okay
but the part about statistics that cares
about inference is basically I would say
it's the same as machine learning
machine learning just gave it a
different name and I think it comes from
your perspective we come from like a
statistics they come more from like the
mathematical modeling and the stochastic
methods and machine learning comes from
let's do it in a computer and let's come
up with more tempting the world I got
here we're not heuristics wrong word but
computational reasons to do it they're
coming from different angles to the same
result and modern statisticians will
they're going for pure prediction also
in the old fashioned statisticians are
doing the inference yeah and it depends
a lot on what you go but the book by
Russia banning hasty and Friedman called
elements of statistical learning I would
claim it's the best machine learning
test book though it says sista sista
cook on the cover so exactly um you're
your last answer about the null
hypothesis in hypothesis testing just
seem to be asking you to be open for
overfitting in the model how the heck
are you going to prevent that and you
know basically your claims of
significance are just on the data itself
but it's it's if you're just overfitting
it's going to cause you problems later
on I think a lot of the modern tools are
designed to try to avoid overfitting the
whole test and train the
cross-validation wa I see like WIC puts
a big penalty on too many parameters
were a bigger penalty than b IC or any
of those and cross validation is indeed
meant for avoiding overfitting and same
holding the
set out anyone all right so before we
get the next question for the audience
out one other question is what's a
different scene over fitting in machine
learning and consulting in machine
learning tip your waitresses thank you
very much uh so like earlier this year
jon kleinberg put out paper of like
impossibility theory um possibly theorem
for clustering which basically says like
no clustering algorithm can satisfy
these like three ideal properties of you
like a clustering algorithm to have sort
of like it's sort of like arrows
impossibility theorem except for
clustering and so like one things he
shows like you can't have a clustering
all of them that is scale invariance so
like when you change like if you just
take your distance function multiplied
by a scalar and also that if you is
consistently if you like shrink the
distances within cluster any expand it
costs a distance cluster like the
algorithm will still produce same
clusters so like now we know like okay
there's no perfect clustering algorithm
what would you think would be like good
properties you'd want for a clustering
algorithm
lord I it depends on what you want out
of your clusters like all the clustering
algorithms have different kinds of
hypothesis and you can like make them
more abstract and make them like axioms
of what you want over to get clustering
but in the end depends what are the
properties that you want out of the
clusters like what is the claim that you
want to make about the cluster and you
cannot make all possible claims because
there's no ed I mean it's pretty clear
that there's no right clustering
algorithm you should say like what is
important in my application and then try
to formalize that and try to like fit
that so one doesn't really exactly
answer your question but one of the
things that I've noticed is sort of bad
property of many clustering algorithm
rhythms is the that they depend a lot on
the random initialization right like
k-means is a classic example and you
know people use k-means all the time and
you can pretty easily just give it some
synthetic data and it'll give you
garbage results and so I think you know
look thinking a lot about initialization
is an important thing for improving the
end result of clustering spectral
methods are pretty good there I also
think that consensus algorithms are very
important there so you know you kind of
you can put this meta machinery on top
of a lot of different types of
algorithms where you sort of look at it
you're like oh well there's no agreement
here so these are probably not good
answers maybe we need to like iterate
some more and figure out something
better until we can come to something
that everybody agrees is good so I think
more investigation in those directions
is very much warranted maybe to add I
mean definitely consensus is very
interesting but there's usually no good
way to validate if you did a good job so
I would always be very careful in
interpreting clusters and it's very if
you have some metric to see like you can
do a B testing or whatever see if you
actually help whatever you wanted to do
doing just inference on some clustering
algorithms you have no idea if your
inference will be correct
I thanks you we're talking earlier about
p values and moving on to all the other
different options i'm curious what you
found if you're working maybe in a large
company with the sponsor that's familiar
with regression and just p values and
there's all these other things we can
tell them about our results for instance
the feature importance and in random
forests and whatnot what you found to be
most effective it kind of communicating
with people to learn more like it's old
school or whatever and particularly when
they ask questions like that's great
that variable x is important but like if
you change it by five percent you know
what happens to my result my prediction
yeah so um I think you know your your
questions incredibly Valley because I
think this is very real world I'm in the
way of explaining how your algorithm
works and what it actually looks like so
some fortunately there's a lot of
algorithms at our disposal that are very
easy to explain especially pictorially
so decision trees allow for this really
you know wonderful illustration of how
things can be classified and as it's
divided in a feature space and KN n is
another that is really easy to explain
and so there are those that are easy to
explain but in in the world where things
get a little more ambiguous um you know
it or difficult to explain let's check
us support vector machine for example I
do believe it's really helpful to
illustrate it I'm pictorially if
possible so PCA can come to our rescue
and allows you to like plot this these
uh these features in this space so so um
you might not be able to explain the
exact algorithm from head to tail but
you can show the did where that held
that hyperplane exists in space so
that's very cool yeah pictures are great
so my experience with explaining PCA has
been abysmal like every time I try to
explain like what are these dimensions
and I'm like well they're like a linear
combination of other dimensions and
people like what
so I don't I've had limited success with
that non-negative matrix factorization
tends to give you more for additive
models tends to give you better akmal
amatory properties which is kind of nice
because they're not these like weird
negative positive mixes so also I think
better models if you if you're in an in
additive model setting you you want to
use non-negative components I've
actually very infrequently want had
anyone want anything to do with p-values
in a business setting so one of the few
cases where I think p-values have come
up and been of some importance is an a/b
testing and knowing you know how long do
we have to run this a/b test in order to
actually have a significant result and
it's a pretty classic it's like one of
the cases where you're like yet no no p
values are exactly what you want here
and I think the issue there is not
actually explaining p-values to people
but setting the problem up so that in
advance they know yeah okay you can't
you know if you're looking for
conversion rates on a you know commerce
site you know conversion rates are very
low so you need a lot of data to support
your your any any sort of significance
so don't expect that you can run this
for like an hour and get results you're
gonna have to run it for weeks maybe you
know maybe a month to figure out that
this is actually going to tell you
something so setting that expectation is
sort of i think the most important part
so maybe maybe this is a lot of
controversial question but python vs r
vs julia for machine learning what are
the pros and more importantly what are
the cons think i can predict how we're
gonna vote here to supplement that
question you could also answer what do
you think is missing an open-source
machine learning for Python or or Julia
what tools libraries techniques
somebody has an opinion I'm gonna
channel West McKinney we need an
underlying table interface okay um so I
everyone here knows of West McKinney I
assume right pandas author so he is
beginning a lot of talk lately about
wanting a1c library to handle all sorts
of table interfaces and he doesn't mean
tabular data he means like JSON style
data and this way it works in see
underneath everything acts the same and
I could do it in our you could do new
Python you do know Julia and just all
have different x is the one API for
bindings of different languages and that
right there would be nice having
everything hope that wasn't me everyone
having a nice simple interface to use to
access the data I know that's not a
machine learning thing yet but that's
crucially important in an answer that
won't get anyone's head chopped off here
just as a follow-up to this there was
recently workshop and Berkeley where we
got together mostly Python people but
also some are in Julia folks and we
basically all agree that's a horrible
idea of course do what won't change
people go away from panacea from our
people from google away from data frame
you won't get a patent people to go away
from numpy and julia we people probably
want to like implement their stuff and
julia and not have to rely on some c++
and we so people discussed about is
quite a lot and they couldn't agree on
how would you store like a missing value
and so it's probably gonna happen yeah
well i might not happen like as the data
centers i don't care what's underneath
the hood and are I just care that could
use our Ryan you probably scare use
Python so let's say it's not someone
like C library but like you want chase
on to be a standard right XML is a
standard so I think it's not so much
about the program and choice like he
wants it there to be some sort of
standard everything just runs fast for
everyone yeah for the record when I was
we were talking about this I didn't
actually think it was a terrible idea I
just didn't think we were gonna do it
I thought it was like if I could just
like snap my fingers and make this thing
happen I'd be like yeah that would be
great but I don't that's dy9 yeah we
talked about that a bit I don't know so
I'm gonna I'm going to talk a little bit
to answer this question about strengths
and weaknesses of Julia with respect to
these other systems so i would say that
for a lot of problems i think this is in
general if you are you know using python
or are or you know whatever you're using
matlab god forbid i'm just kidding it's
just because it's not open source but
but if you're using a tool and you're
happy with it you should continue to use
it the people who are ready to try
something else or either going to do
that because I think it's exciting and
interesting because it's new or because
they're in a world of pain like they
have a problem that they are not
currently able to solve with their
existing tools so you know for Julia one
of our pitches is that you know we
combine high productivity with high
performance so if you're in this world
where you know actually you've
previously been forced to write
everything in C++ because you need the
performance but see post boss is painful
to write then you might want to consider
it because you can get a lot of the ease
of use for machine learning specifically
i think you know i i'm not going to get
into comparing python vs are but
obviously these are more mature systems
i think that if you can if you can
process your data on your local machine
and you know python or are cutting it
you should probably continue to do that
there's a lot of really interesting new
libraries that are more scalable and
have high performance that are coming
out of Julia but you know again I think
it's the people people know if they're
in that in that world where they need to
try it I also think if you're
implementing these things it's a it's a
pretty good language I'm going to talk a
little bit later in my talk about how
it's art gives library implementers
superpowers so if you're a person who is
implementing new cutting-edge machine
learning algorithms it might make your
life a lot easier
because you know again you don't have to
write it in C or C++ but you can get
that kind of performance I think a lot
of it comes down to the stack that
you're working with if you're at a shop
that's already everything else is
already in Python you should do your
machine learning in Python because it
just integrates if you're at a shop
where it's not all in Python it's you
know you're using a whole mixture of
tools then use whichever is best for you
some people that's are some people
that's Python some people that's Julia
so it really just comes down to how does
it integrate the rest your ecosystem at
that point and what you personally love
yeah I'll just um so the boot camp that
I work at Medus we teach Python the core
of our curriculum is Python so 11 of the
12 weeks is pure python but even though
having said that um we really encourage
our students to learn our as well so if
someone's looking to put themselves in a
position that is most advantageous upon
um looking for a job after graduating
the boot camp um learning both is just a
stellar move and learning Julie on top
of it is it is incredible so I'm not I'm
the meeting each one of these guys um
and saying each has advantages but I
think that's the best the best route if
it's possible but yeah the good news is
these languages are not radically
different so once you've learned to
program in one you can kind of transfer
that knowledge pretty easily it's like
speaking multiple languages right like
you know once you've learned Italian
French is not that hard and maybe going
back to the pros and cons a little bit
and definitely if your stack is all
writing one language probably easiest to
stay in that language and so people
often ask me should i go to python from
our or why shouldn't i use our and said
and i think for a lot of very specific
set of six models there there are but
not in pison so if you say like oh I
need this particular statistical test or
this particular method then it's more
likely that it's there an are but it's
more likely trickier to find any
algorithm for example in scikit-learn
which is more like one place with the
univer interface
and Python often integrates more better
with the glue coach like you have you
can do more easily like interface with
web stuff and so on but that being said
like I really so for the library writer
so I right stuff for so I can learn I
don't I have to spend time using vol
grind and GD b and g prof to debug and
profile c code lot i don't really like
that and it's generated c code this
course is generated from sizin if i
could debug and profile like in a nice
language maybe Julia if there was like
given the right tool bikes good that
would be much nicer so if you have to
write a lot of high-performance code
yourself when you can use site and you
can use number as Travis probably would
say now but yeah it would be nice to
have everything in one place it is
really nice when you like the low level
code is still in the same language it
makes the development and the debugging
experience much nicer yeah maybe number
will do this what I don't know um this
question is mostly for andreas and
Stefan what responsibility do you feel
in balancing making the api's for these
machine learning models easy such that
data scientists can use them and making
them too easy such that people who don't
really know what they're doing can kind
of chuck garbage in and get garbage out
um I feel very little responsibility to
prevent people from putting garbage into
things and getting garbage out because I
don't think it's possible to prevent I
in terms of API design a generally
favored a layered approach such that
there's a very high level easy to use
layer that you can prototype rapidly in
and not really think about any of the
you know performance details that's
built then in turn built on top of a
lower layer that gives you more control
but is slightly more difficult right
maybe you need to allocate memory
yourself and pass it into a function
instead of having it allocate memory and
give it back to you
and that that layering lets you the idea
is that it like lets you sort prototype
a really easy thing and then when you
find a spot that's not the best
performance re like is your bottleneck
it's pretty easy to just sort of like
step down a layer in the API until you
get the performance you need yeah so I
also don't feel any responsibility to
like limit people and so was complaining
to me like you made everything way too
easy now everybody can use machine
learning now it's like yes we won I'd
like to take one more question from the
audience and then we'll get closing
notes from our panelists so so far you
basically talked about all these tools
which I actually feel a little bit
overwhelmed with all the available data
and tools we have but so all these
things are growing exponentially but do
you think our understanding of data our
ability to transform data to some
insightful information is also growing
as fast yeah I just want to know your
opinion what
yes so um I think that what's wonderful
about the accessibility of these
packages and all of these languages um
we have the ability to not spend the
time creating the algorithm they're here
for us we can spend time really
realizing their potential with data so
essentially we can implement models
within maybe many models within a day
and we can learn up the pros and cons of
this model in that model with this data
set in that data set so there is so much
trial and error but we're able to do
this because we have all these amazing
tools we're so lucky and a few years ago
many of more than five six years ago we
couldn't say that so um yeah I think it
is growing because there's a lot of
learning through trial and error um but
i believe it's growing yeah yeah
absolutely our ability to understand
data is just getting better and better
all the time I the few months ago I got
an NFL linebacker to buy into an
ensemble model and see the results that
it will do and everything we're doing is
just get the things we could pull off of
data just everyday growing with these
methods and tools it's so much enhancing
our ability to understand it and do more
yeah I agree but I think also we are
kind of liking behind in some aspects so
I think with regard to the black box e
models that's a lot of what cycle Ernst
doing we're doing quite well but with
the more introspection we're so more
behind so in particular in the open
source world like visualization is so
there's not one good solution yet for
doing visualization like you're teaching
d3 yet and because like maybe that's
what people are using their smell outlet
but it's not really specific to data
staff they're seaborne there's bouquet
and so on but then also all of these
also mostly mean that you need to write
your custom visualizations for each job
there's nothing like tableau so there's
no open source tableau that's something
that's much more in the exploratory side
which much more helps you to understand
what's actually happening before you put
it in any black box I think there we are
lacking behind I can you open source
community there but someone create that
yeah so I think that these are these are
sort of i think that the the
understanding and ability to unto to to
say what data means is always going to
trail behind your tools because without
the tools you can't do the analysis in
the first place and the first thing you
get is you're going to be like okay
we're going to try some analyses isn't
like that you know maybe this explains
things and then at some point there's
sort of that moment of insight and you
really get it and then you know some
years later that type of analysis
becomes completely standard and
something that is extremely well
understood so i think we are making
progress but yeah it's frustratingly
slow it's fundamentally a philosophical
advance right and that's always slow
it's always difficult so I'd like to
give our panelists an opportunity to
give some closing remarks the title of
this panel was the future of machine
learning so I think a question that you
can meditate upon is what are you most
excited about in machine learning in the
next five to ten years there is a bonus
question you can answer is open-source
important no why is open-source
important why is open-source critical
and there is a cash bonus if you mention
them focus what's the bonus let's see
what I have on me 25 cents yeah i mean i
think that uh i mean open source is
obviously crucial so so i don't know if
people know this here but since I'm
pandering for this for this num focus
thing obviously none focus there's a
number of very important projects that
are you know part of another num focus
organization including Julia syfy numpy
one of the art projects we almost got
our core right but that's the open side
that is in a different consortium but
it's a really great organization for for
numerical software all of it open source
course I don't know I mean I think just
in general first for science and the
advancement of society and understanding
things it's it's reprehensible to have
things locked away behind proprietary
software that can't be reproduced
without paying money i mean this happens
to people were they like go to college
and they use some you know some matlab
for example to do all of their numerical
analysis work and then they graduate
they can't run their own code and that
that's really terrible you know we can't
really we can't we can't have our
society's advancement resting on that as
the foundation so so James didn't find
anything in his wallet so so there's a
asked two questions about open sourcing
about what we find most exciting I mean
open source is absolutely critical
exists allows anybody in the world to go
and build a model reproduce your code
you can do this in any country anywhere
as long as you have a slight internet
connection go explore someone else's
code so hey you gotta do the science and
be if you don't know the times you get
to learn it so it's pretty amazing open
source without it I'm not sure how many
people in this room would be doing what
we're doing as far as what I find most
exciting which I'm not sure you answered
that question just you didn't I just saw
this new I guess algorithm or it would
be the right way to put it from jerry
friedman from elements of statistical
learning to see the rule fit algorithm
it didn't get a lot of fanfare i think
it did get some fanfare but basically it
takes you takes all your data first
builds a gradient boosted tree takes the
results of that plus the continuous
variables into an elastic net and a
corner him he is the creator it's come
up some really great results so i'm
actually I've always been a huge fan of
the lasso in the elastic net and feel
now we're combining a gradient boosted
tree with that and if it gets the
results he's claiming at the speed he's
claiming that's just super cool why
don't you ever wish that he published it
maybe a month ago oh yeah but there's
like a two-year-old paper might an old
paper oh yeah there's like Microsoft did
that publish that footing at a click
prediction which means they're not using
it anymore so huh but oh it's actually
thought but i recommend of doing that in
my large-scale talking by Gotham that's
right that's pretty good idea yeah okay
it's based on like about a 13 year old
paper yeah they just released a software
a month ago how can yeah yeah okay so
but so i don't think i have to like talk
about how awesome open sources because
you're all here already so you have to
talk about how awesome open source
helping sauce is awesome and I'm focus
helps us all to make more awesome open
source I'm also they bring the beautiful
stickers for us so some for you to take
a take a cut and pass it off okay so
then I take the Canadian money there's
what languages Canada can oh this is old
Canadian I think this is valid on him so
what I'm most excited about is like
basically two opposite directions the
one that I talked about having more
interactive visualization having easier
way to people to directly see what's
happening a data set go from a CSV file
to incite in like quicker time I mean
panis is amazing but I have to write a
lot of pandas code before i actually get
visualization that i need and the other
thing is more black box to things like
built a brick in model go from csv file
to a thing that gives me a class
prediction without doing anything
there's companies that do it they're
like their state a robot for example and
there's research behind it like there's
ottawa sk learn which does some crazy
stuff to predict which best which is the
best model for use on which data set
awesome i want to talk talk to more to
these people that don't have time but i
definitely think that is a very good
direction when we started come to leak
opposite ends I think you should have
more manual inside but having something
that gives you automatically the best
machine learning algorithm awesome
yes so being in the educational sphere
what am most excited about right now is
something i ran across recently called
machine teaching which takes the machine
learning model and it turns it on its
head so you're uh you already have your
learning algorithm and your learning
algorithm is your student and that's the
way that student learns is dependent
depending on my algorithm then you use
is dependent on how the student learns
so you have your algorithm and the
hyperplane is already known and what
you're looking for is the ideal training
set to teach the students so it's really
fascinating to UM to even think about so
even though we were dogging on a neural
Nets earlier I think it's really
interesting because these um the
algorithm is based on how the human
brain works and so you have this like
the brain and forming the algorithm but
in the case of machine teaching you have
the algorithm informing the brain so you
can imagine like this amazing positive
feedback loop and makes me think we're
in a really good place for to be in the
tech seer so that's what's exciting and
to add to the positive feedback loop is
the open source so it's again um it
mimics that positive feedback loop
because you were just continuing to
compound our knowledge again and again
again in an expansion ille exponential
manner so yeah so I'd like if you could
join me in thanking all of our excellent
panelists and our co-moderator
you
you